it's pride month you came out
last year which is amazing
and i feel like the reception has
probably been awesome
you also recently talked about coming
out
so first of all for you on your end what
has the reception
been like oh what a great question
um you know when i came out a year ago
i really thought that was gonna be it
and i thought i'd like said it
and i thought everybody just like knew
and i also think that because
i have been out in my own
personal life since ever since i can
remember i think the first time i had a
conversation about my sexuality i was
like eight years old
with my mom and anybody who i've met
since then
it's very like oh yeah i'm i guess my
whole life i've said i'm i'm bi
oh yeah i'm bi and it's just been sort
of like a oh okay
nobody's ever been like what because i
think i do present with
energy that is not you know conducive to
i don't think it's like a big shock
ever once you get to know me really and
so when i came out last year i really
was like oh
great and and there it is right
and then when the gay times cover came
out
last week i was shocked with how many
people
were shocked it's been interesting it's
definitely been interesting i think like
um last year last year felt
safer to me because i there just wasn't
as much of a reaction
and so i was kind of like oh okay great
great
and then this time around i woke up i
just didn't realize how
it's an interesting feeling when
something so intrinsic
and and like pure about who you are um
means anything at all to people which is
not to say that i'm
surprised by that or i didn't know that
it's an interesting feeling
like pressure or almost
it just feels like suddenly everybody's
in your living room like it just
suddenly feels like everybody
yeah it's very strange and there aren't
that many things that
um i feel that way about because
obviously i think you know me i'm very
very open
and so it's been an interesting like
week processing
that with the amount of text messages i
got and lovely lovely support like a lot
of support
uh from my like you know queer family my
lgbtq family
and important people in my life or
people who i barely know you know it's
been
really really wonderful i think it's
just a sort of a an adjustment to
um being witnessed in that way by
by people who aren't important to you
you know like the world has an opinion
about something that is
so um just natural i'm definitely
adjusting to that but it's um it's it's
for the most part it's been really
really wonderful and it feels um new
i feel very new i love that and i'm just
so happy for you
what did surprise me in in the interview
in the gay times
is that you said that you were worried
that people wouldn't
believe you or you thought you wouldn't
be accepted
and i guess i'm curious like do you
still feel that way or why did you feel
that way
i don't feel that way as much anymore
i've been speaking to a lot of my
my queer identifying friends
this week about you know that feeling of
do i belong here that feeling of like
even even if you've known who you are
your whole life i think there's a sort
of a common feeling of like
oh but i i can't enter into the lgbtq
community because
you know all these reasons that we that
we make up in our head
i think there there have been a couple
times in my personal life where i've
told somebody
who i was and it was received with
skepticism
or like i was maybe you know some kind
of misconception about
what sexuality really means to someone
you know i think there have been a few
times where i've
i've i've stated purely and simply who i
am and someone's gone
but not really right but not really
you're so girly
or you know you're so right as if you
could get into a box or something
right right and i think that because of
that and because it is something so
personal i just got it in my head i was
like oh god what if that happens all
over the world what if that happens in a
mass scale then i'm constantly
defending something that is something
that is just like so
me and so intimate i don't want to be i
don't want to do that am i ready to feel
that way all the time
am i ready to constantly go to bat with
someone who doesn't even deserve
my energy around this because they're
gonna question something that is so
intrinsic
to me like definitely i am facing a lot
of that people being like oh well
she's only ever you know publicly dated
men or
you know all kinds of things like this
that people think that they know about
you especially when you live out loud
like me i think every i think a lot of
people think they know
everything about someone like me they
show so much you could have dated a
woman and maybe it was a private
relationship
and we didn't know about it but you're
saying people just make these
assumptions because
of who you've posted with in the past or
who you've posed in a picture with
or you know they think i'm feminine and
they think that femininity has something
to do with sexuality it's you know it's
all very like
enmeshed and broken and yeah but yeah
i'm i am
i am definitely like you know i think it
was very important that i did that
for myself and also for my young fans
who are so impressionable
i think that it's so important um i did
it for me
i did it for me but i think that the
beautiful thing about living your life
for yourself
is then you make room for other people
to live
their lives for themselves when in
whatever way that means to them and
that's very important to me
yeah and to even just spark the
conversation the more it's talked about
the better it is oh yeah now we need to
destigmatize like basically everything
right like stigma is such an ego based
like unnecessary you know it's like it's
old it's old we're bored you know i
think we just need to destigmatize
everything and
rehumanize everything and then we'll be
like
what does pride month mean to you
at this point oh well this is going to
be my first pride month like really
really out
so yeah my friend i know yay
my friend texted me the other day and
was like this month is for you and i was
like oh
you know it's like you feel i was like
wow there's a lot of like emotion
around um my coming out that i didn't
really anticipate
because i've always been out in my in my
private life so i was sort of like yeah
one emotion you know it's like i had to
be just like
i knew i was going to come out but it's
very uh
it's different i feel different you know
being out and
and having people say things like that
to me like happy pride month i'm like oh
thank you
thanks i'm you know i'm usually the one
wishing happy pride month and counting
myself like an ally
yeah so so yeah it's special it's
special i need to figure out what i'm
gonna do
i think it's amazing and i'm so happy
for you and i'm so happy that your story
is out there and that people um are
receiving it so well
and learning and that it's been such a
positive
thing yeah thank you thank you
[Music]